the worst was when I went to kme and at
the time I'd been doing gigs I'd done a
a really real lucky gig I was asked by a
event coordinator to do a gig for their
client and would I meet their client
first and would I Caravan behind her to
the car the client's house so I said
okay and I followed her and uh we went
up to Malibu and we turned off just by
Paradise Cove and went up the canyon and
she this is Barbara and this is Richard
no not Barbara strian exactly are you
kidding me Barbara strian she was my
first big big gig that I did and it was
her son's bar mitzvah for uh Jason gold
the some of Elliot and and Barbara and
she put on this in she was the nicest
person everyone said afterwards oh God
yeah she such a [__] and all this kind
of stuff she couldn't have been nice if
you show up and do your job she treated
did you like gold the waitress who
served me my food was Barbara stren I
mean couldn't have been nicer and she
had everyone there I mean David geffin
was there Neil Diamond was there were
you Star Struck not by her because I
didn't play her music much I was in the
clubs at the time if it had been Anita
Ward who was there you could Ring My
Bell but also didn't she have that song
and we got nothing to be guilty of a
little disco yeah a little disco and um
she you don't bring me flowers with Neil
Diamond I play that in the ballad
section but obviously I knew who she was
I knew she was one of the biggest
singers in the world but there were so
many other people there um Larry Hagman
was there and so yeah and that was the
great thing he enjoyed the party so much
he took one of my business cards and
then I did the party at his house for
the rap party for season one of Dallas
so wait a minute you started doing so
people Word of Mouth are you saying Word
of Mouth Word of Mouth Richard Blade
he's the guy dick dick sheeper at the
time dick Shephard and then you saw a
movie Ryan you might have heard of this
called Blade Runner no well I saw it
advertised you know because the whole
thing was I did all these parties and
then I did one for ziaa kabore oh yeah
and that was up in the the hills on one
of the stilt houses right and there were
two people there that I was just
thrilled to meet one of them was my
all-time favorite movie actor and I
never met him before and the amazing
thing was I met him again two weeks
later never never again who he came up
to me I I I saw him and I said that you
know could I tell you something kind of
weird and he said why what and I said I
I went to school with a wet underarm
because of you for about 3 weeks and he
why would that be and I said because my
James Bond water pistol shoulder holster
kept leaking and he goes you know I had
one of those as well I used to collect
all of the memorabilia from the Bond
movie season Conor I know and he was
incredible he was every you see you're
meeting your Heroes and they're nice but
that's rare and they were everything you
wanted them to be that's he he looked
like met a lot of [__] Rich I've met
a lot of [__] you know if he looked
like if he punched you you were going
down he looked like tough guy a real man
he he looked like Bond